we Europeans suffer from the greatest
human tragedy since the wars we are all
heartbroken by the death of many
thousands of people killed by the
coronavirus the first and hardest hit
are Italy in Spain and we are mourning
with them our daily life has changed
dramatically
millions of people cannot go to work but
they still have to buy groceries and pay
the bills companies are paying salaries
to their employees even if right now
they are not making money Europe is now
coming to their support with a new
initiative it is called sure for example
the regions around mulana or Madrid they
are part of the backbone of Europe's
economy thousands of strong and healthy
companies are struggling because of the
current crisis they need our support to
get through the crisis and this is why
we have developed a concept of short
time work it is intended to help Italy
Spain and all other countries that have
been hearted and it will do so thanks to
the Solidarity of other Member States
how does sure work we have learned the
lessons from the financial crisis in
2008 Member States who had this
instrument helped millions of people to
stay in their jobs and companies to go
through the financial crisis with their
employees this is sure state-supported
short-time work it has mitigated the
effects of the recession kept people in
work and enabled companies to return to
the markets with renewed vigor and the
idea is simple if there are no orders
and companies run out of work because of
a temporary external shock like aronia
they should not lay off their workers
they continue to employ them even if
there's less work in the spare time
workers might be taught for example news
skills that will benefit both the
company and themselves this way people
are spared the hole in their wallets
during the crisis they can continue to
pay the rents and buy what they need and
this also has a positive impact on the
economy thanks to sure more people will
keep their job during the corona crisis
and they will go back to full work as
soon as the lockdown will be over when
the demand picks up again and the orders
come back this is crucial to restart
Europe's economic engine without delay
this week the European Commission will
propose a new instrument to support
short time work it will help in the
countries the most hit and it is
guaranteed by all Member States this is
European solidarity in action it is for
Italy Spain and others and it is for
Europe's future